thank you
[Music]
Australian female who changed her mind
about transitioning into a man
has filed a lawsuit against their
psychiatrist for approving their gender
reassignment after just one meeting oh
that is one message crazy
one meeting one meeting at 19 years old
Jay lagondi no I don't [ __ ] know it's
Australian shirts began meeting with Dr
Patrick Tuohy a long time time
psychiatrist in Sydney Australia
her endocrinologist whatever that is
referred her to Dr Patrick to see if she
would be able to receive a gender
transition oh that's a hormone doctor
for the endocrine system monthly just
call it that is this the endocrine
system yeah you know what they should
just call it the horny doc because if
it's hormonal it's just super hard I'm a
sexual doctor if he doesn't have horns
according to a statement of a claim
filed in the New South Wales Supreme
Court The Physician explained from their
perspective that log on dinos was young
and needed a throughout psychiatric
workup before embarking on hormone
treatment but she's 19 though isn't she
sounds reasonable though right she's a
full-on adult no isn't she adult should
make her own decisions so she's having a
meeting first about should I do this she
was meeting yeah with her
endocrinologist and then they were
referred to Dr Patrick to have so like
actually suss out if this was going to
be a good move right so the two met up
Dr Patrick declared that lagandinos was
going through gender dysphoria and that
she could begin testosterone therapy
immediately and between 2010 2021 uh
lagandinos underwent test testosterone
therapy Top surgery and also had her
uterus removed oh that's [ __ ] that's so
funny they regret it oh yes so she's she
is now suing that psychology after 11
years of being a male now he wants to be
a she again so yeah she no longer
identifies as a male so that's what I'm
saying she and she's claiming that Dr
Patrick was professionally negligent in
his recommendations for her in a lawsuit
she also says that Dr Patrick should
have recommended she get a second
opinion before her hysterectomy and that
her social phobia should have been
considered in his recommendations to her
after she expressed that condition so
she thinks she should have been denied
yes yes wow that's really hard because a
lot of people right now are complaining
about that the process takes too long
well this is in Australia so I think
it's a little different than in the
states yeah the time differences but
there there are people that have
transitioned the time there are people
that have transitioned and they're
coming out now saying like don't [ __ ]
do it they don't tell you about the
medical issues that you go through from
transitioning the hormones you have to
continuously take until you die the
surgery it's not smooth all the time
like even afterwards like when you
transition your genitals and stuff the
care the they don't like a lot of places
I guess didn't warn the people so now
they're suing the people that
transitioned and they don't they regret
it and they want to go back or whatever
they're suing because they're like we
weren't educated with everything and
also if we speak out about it the
community goes against them as well as
everybody else and they're just like
they're betraying the community it's
like you're a heretic of of that yeah
but it's like but it's a strange thing
too because there are some people who
are like who got it and they're like I'm
happier now I'm better now I love it
like I'm very happy so it's it's one of
those things where this it's a
case-by-case thing and some some people
are saying that uh the medical industry
is heavily incentivized to have people
do these surgeries that's what I'm
thinking yeah there's like there's no
way if you think about it how many women
do you know that got breast implants
were not happy with it oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
and that's supposed to be the same
surgery but it isn't yeah my friend
almost died from that yeah Kanye's mom
died from that yeah they probably also
don't set the stage for that either
right like they don't tell you the risks
of that it's a tough situation when like
they go hey doctor can you help me and
the doctors like sure I'll help you and
then they're like why the [ __ ] you help
me for yeah you know that's like some of
the responsibility has to be on the
person applying for it right they're
signing off on paperwork yeah and
especially about the second opinion part
it's like you should always if you're
that's on you to get a second yeah like
if you're always gonna if you're gonna
get a big surgery you should get a
second opinion always right you're never
gonna get any service profession and
then like you pull your car into Jiffy
Lube and they're like I could change
your oil but I would check with the guy
down the street too yeah yeah no one
does that and if it's Australia doesn't
that mean that majority of this is free
probably
I'm not sure I don't know the answer
though there might be a difference
between like uh
uh likes uh dumb word I don't know if
it's like a uh Healthcare to do with
yeah elected yeah yeah you can't say
that yeah but you wouldn't be able to
call it elective surgery it's not extra
credit can't say elective
because then that's saying that it's a
core requirement okay
that wouldn't be necessary okay
Cosmetics because we take it just to
[ __ ] around
just to add to what BART was saying too
it's like you're going to a psychiatrist
which means that in that moment your
mental state as an adult it's your
decision to want something yeah
so it's like such a great area for
psychiatrists to like check you on that
but is a 19 year old an adult
because according to my mother you're
not
[Laughter]
that's a great point but I think in the
rest of the hundred percent of the world
you are an adult Steve Green's been
America Stephen's Mom I don't know about
Australia but I think in American terms
adults are 30. that's in American terms
well we're not offered for insurance
until 26 right okay 26. FedEx but you
can be tried and as adult at like 16
development here people aren't really
adults until 30.
18 year olds and maybe Thailand are
adults but I don't know I think 30 is a
good age that's super hard because like
that you you really hear a lot about the
trans Community wanting to expedite the
entire process of like gaining solution
there or even moving it down a younger
age like yeah they should stop yeah like
everything's trying to be done faster
and better and sooner right yeah but
then this wasn't the idea of that from
what I understand it is like you want to
maintain like if you're going to try to
go against what your genes are like at
least like you know because of where the
way your body's developing you need to
do something about it so you in order to
be passing or more passing you have to
cut it off at the pass earlier so that
it already hits yeah
it can already start adapting yeah yeah
so that you're more like there than
developed like you can turn it around
quicker is the idea I've heard that one
was it um something going down in Canada
Canada where the father
was getting something was going down
because his daughter wanted to
transition
and and she was under age or he was
under age or something like that there's
been a couple a lot of cases yeah yeah
and then
he was like no don't do that
and then it was like there was this
weird gray area law where like now the
kids have all the power to make that
decision and the parents can't do [ __ ]
and there's that's starting to happen
where it's like it used to be a D Wade's
uh daughter
oh really really same thing well d-way
was like signing uh like uh saying that
he's he's uh like oh come on I'm gonna
bushes yeah do it yeah uh so so I'll do
it yeah
uh the uh yeah he will say like uh to to
legally or one legally switched the name
and then lately switch to gender as well
uh like he was gonna like sign off from
it or he's like going to make the
petition for his daughter now like you
know yeah legally but medically too or
not or just legally like on papers I
don't know actually but he's green
lighting it right yeah so in my example
it's the parents don't even have any
control over it now or I think it was I
think it was the there was a father
maybe I think I know you're talking
about right and then the dad was like
don't do it don't do it and the mom was
like no we're gonna transition our kid
and then they fought in court and I
think the dad lost
and so I think that the dad has to just
sit there and watch it happen wow and
there's another I think it's in
California but I'm butching all these
things because like I'm not I don't have
Google in front of me but like
there's something where it's either past
or it's on the bill but now kids are
gonna be able to just
choose and it doesn't want I want
hormonal therapy I'm just gonna get it
and if the parents don't give it to them
it's like child abuse or there's just
some [ __ ] up [ __ ] going on right now
oh yeah I read something where if the
kid wants I don't know where this is at
but it's moving in a direction where if
the kid wants it and the parent says no
Then it is uh like negligence of some
sort now the social worker can take the
kid away yeah something like that yeah
there's also some stories about schools
that have helped to transition kids
without the knowledge of the parent
because they believe what damn you again
certain cases right not happening
everywhere necessarily but the new Norm
right yeah it's new it's a new this is
all a new paradigm right so then that
that is uh something that parents are
looking at and citing and saying
yo I want the school to just [ __ ]
teach my kids certain things I don't
want you guys to be like like steering
their life like this yeah that what I
find interesting regardless of like the
psychiatrist and all the whatever is one
somebody uh identifying as a male
and then I'm not saying change their
mind for lack of a better service but
I'm going to say it for a lack of a
better term like kind of change their
mind and no longer identifying like
regardless you know what I'm saying like
I don't know if I would immediately
immediately be like it's a
psychiatrist's fault you know what I'm
saying like that that seems like such a
personal experience and such a personal
decision yeah that's what I mean there's
like the the person needs to have some
sort of responsibility but isn't there
something to
um you know we all talk about getting
expert expert help and expert advice and
and experts sitting you sitting with you
for one meeting and sort of the way that
um
with certain pharmaceutical companies
they'll meet with you barely even
[ __ ] talk to you barely even meet you
get you give you the biggest pain meds
ever yeah just like right some doctors
will just nod their heads and be like
all right all right all right all right
here you go right and so there's a
there's a crony uh aspect to it yes yeah
that I think maybe has some weight that
we'll see how it goes but you know I
think care is what we're all hoping for
when we go to these places some extra
consideration yeah and a second a real
second opinion not just me with my
opinion about my body per se but can I
talk to an expert about this and just
and see what what's maybe going on under
the hood and maybe you know in herc and
in his case or not her case
um
they're like yeah I think I got a bad
opinion from somebody who didn't really
care so okay so it's more of not the
fact that she changed her mind
necessarily but that the psychiatrist
didn't set the stage of what's gonna
happen or they didn't do their job fully
yeah it's kind of like hey after one
meeting exactly like did you really
assess me right because yeah one meeting
sounds crazy one [ __ ] meeting like we
should have had a whole session maybe
it's like several months and then made
an assessment like yeah this is of sound
mind and it's like they should be
transitioned yeah and then sign off on
that versus like you come in for an oil
change and then they even check
everything right but but then there are
people who come in for the oil change
and then they're like you got to fix
this this this this and you just sign
off on it you're like sure I trust you I
don't know what the [ __ ] I'm doing yeah
it's the same kind of situation I think
for something is that pretty standard
like if you're gonna do a gender
reassignment that you talk to a
psychiatrist before yeah it's one of the
even in the states too huh yeah I think
it's pretty mad in Canada too because
you have to be like kind of like
co-signed that it's
because you have either what is it not
gender dysmorphia it's like some kind of
there is gender dysm yeah yeah but like
your sound mind to do this like some
people like you don't know like unless
you're a trained professional you don't
know if they're just doing it for other
reasons yeah well maybe there's some
kind of trauma right maybe yeah
something happened to them
um not saying this happens at all
everybody it's great if it's complex
maybe something happened to them and
then they're trying to just get away
from their sense of self yeah and so
they go somewhere else and they don't
really want that you just don't know
yeah it's it's pretty cool because
someone really close to me is like
currently going full transition same
right now and I'm getting like a really
good sense of what it's like and uh with
every little step of the way are loads
of evaluations every single step it's
not like someone meets with you and goes
okay yeah go ahead and do all of it it's
like every little inch of that they're
having to do so much and they're always
like super stressed out because they're
like I gotta go back and do this and
that and then there's always the thought
of like am I giving the wrong info and
not gonna get what I want or like
there's so many questions because it's
all never really been done and there's
no one to look to to be like oh but then
also I I also understand the whole like
when I'm listening to them telling me
what it's like I'm just like cool like
that's what it is I don't have any
opinion or objection I'm like that's
what you think you want that's what you
want but then also that must be weird to
be the doctor because the doctor is not
trans and a lot of the time like the you
know in the trans Community it's a very
like
long said thing that like no sis CIS
Hitman cannot decide what trans people
need but that's a CIS had doctor so it's
like what what exactly pressure is that
doctor feeling to go yeah you know I
think you should have it or I think you
shouldn't because there's a lot of like
anger that doctor probably doesn't want
to be to doesn't want to be known as the
one that's like you know what I need to
see you two more time there's a lot of
anger towards the doctors that won't do
it too yeah like there's a lot of that
out there one of five meetings just to
[ __ ] if I pull money out of me so I feel
like their yeses and those are different
too I have a cousin going through this
same [ __ ] and kind of like you when I
hear about what's going on with him now
um all I can do is just judge the [ __ ]
out of it with my own personal
you know [ __ ] all over yeah yeah like my
own personal partisan side yeah is what
I cling to well I just judge the [ __ ]
out of what he's going through that's
Brave you dude thank you good for you
bro thank you guys thank you seriously I
don't get to talk about everyone
everybody needs to see you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]